We've got four months of being dishonest. This isn't like a oh
man, this 100% truthful guy. This 100% truthful guy just happened
to take a donut at that time. And he's he's listening to him
talk about the chats. He's hearing the words. The words are,
"Hey, yeah, yeah, there there's 50 chats in 5 minutes. That's
completely different than just a mirror image. It's completely
contradicting your entire point." And he's going, "Oh, thanks
for hitting the donut goal, Johnny."
Well,
I wonder what legal legal mindset's take was on the Ethan uh
on the Ethan Klein lawsuit. I wonder if this would be transformative
under that same provision. Stop telling me to do jumping jacks.
That has nothing to do with hiccups. Okay, doing hiccups. [__]
Doing jumping jacks would not help hiccups. You were just trying
to get me to embarrass myself on stream. Awful video.
Awful video. Oh my god. Anyway, yeah, there we go. Just thought
I'd check in on Techone.
See what utter
he's got going on. Yeah, lovely stuff. Lovely doxing. Doxing,
dude. Absolutely. Oh my god. Has yeet turned on Dioro?
I literally I just refreshed Twitter and saw this. It's like
an hour and a half ago. Finally,
the dawn knows what it's like to step outside the cabal.
Dan Saltman and Nicholas Yuri have been going back and forth
all day. Disagreement stems from a son crash out on on chatter.
You make us all look worse by comparison through bad faith.
Why is it bad faith? Find an attorney who agrees with you. I'm
correct. Where's the other one? Where is the other one? Come
on. I saw another one. Wait, is this an edited version? This
is edited.
Oh, no, it did. Okay, this one exists as well.
Nicholas Dioro defends Hassan's viral crash out. Says he didn't
duk anyone due to pulling up a public YouTube channel. Quote,
"All this tells me is that you're completely morally bankrupt
and unable to acknowledge when people are lying.
There are so many examples of Assan getting special treatment.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, Nick is just right. Nick is just correct. If your
response to any of the above blatant lies is, but he brandish
a fake gun. First of all, I agree with that. I think there should
be a 24-hour ban at minimum. Wait, I thought he was I thought
he was defending.
No. Okay, but all this tells me is that completely morally bankrupt
and able to acknowledge lying. There are loads of examples of
Assan getting special treatment from over Twitch. We don't need
to make up a fake doxing claim to enhance your apathetic fake
gunishing
dude. Dude. Okay, Nick is totally based here. Uncritical
Dioro support. Also, if your response to this thread/evidence
is, he took off the orange tip and that's illegal in the state
of California, I just want you to know that I loathe you.
Oh my god.
Oh my god. The thing is about Dorio is he is and I I I'm not
going to I'm not going to level it as like a as like a serious
a serious claim that I'm actually you know you know over.
He's incredibly smug.
He's incredibly egotistical
and he's insanely smmy.
So when he's disagreeing with you, incredibly easy to hate.
Incredibly easy to hate. But when he's arguing on your side,
God does it feel good. It feels so good. Okay. I am seal clapping
right now. I am seal clapping.
Okay. Um,
right. I tried to do it sucking in. That didn't really work.
Yeah, I'll do like a Okay, never mind. Ignore that.
Got to go back and delete that later. Please don't clip that
bad seal noise.
Dan Saltman and Nicholas Doro been going back and forth all day.
Okay.
Oh my god,
I just realized now. I just realized now how much text that is.
Why did I read all that? Okay, this you get nerd.
I saw that where Dioria goes ahead and links his his YouTube
channel, two pictures of his face, and then his kick channel.
Why are you arguing with me, Lau? I didn't write the law or Twitch's
to find an attorney who says you are
This is obviously a contract/legal
issue and not a feeling issue. Maybe Pisco will back you up.
I'll accept it if he
Also, if you're not aware,
Diorio,
Dan Saltman absolutely
hates Dioria.
If you don't know, Dan Saltman absolutely
hates Pisco.
Got to get Dioria out of my mind. He's He's captivating me. Enslave.
Never mind. Nick says, "Because you're a discourse who makes
us all look worse by comparison through bad faith attacks like
this one.
Dad says, "Why is it bad faith?
When should we substitute our own feelings off what something
is
versus what the law says? You are not really engaging with anything
in my post." Just calling me bad faith. I mean, that is true.
But I do agree with them.
I'm not even sure what you disagree with. Twitch calls it doxing.
Canada law cal Canada
Canada
California law calls it doxing a question mark I mean isn't that
the meat of the claim I mean realistically
is Diorio engaging here no
Dorio is just like with him right so has got the love handles
on his mind
they're too heavy to get off you sent me this screenshot last
night ignored the word sensitive information and could then you
admitted it wasn't uh illegal doxing last night live on stream
and mostly a critique of Twitch's policies you intentionally
misread
you have frantically been trying to find a new position to better
fit your end goal all night clearly I read it on Twi I read it
on um I watched the stream last night and yeah he did Dan was
saying when I when I mean illegal um when I mean illegal I just
mean like according to the Twitch Yes.
Dip [__] No, you don't.
It's just so obviously dishonest.
And Diorio dickers. And Dioro has no idea who Pisco is. Question
mark. I don't know. I don't know if Diorio has any idea who Pisco
is. I'm pretty sure he actually does cuz he's a big fan of Destiny's
content or at least was. So,
Find find an attorney who agrees with you. knock. I mean, Dan
Saltman is what trying to flame Nick over the fact that he doesn't
actually respond to any of his uh tweets and then here he is
completely swerving past the fact that he's operating in complete
bad faith and has changed his position in real time and says,
"Fuck it. I'll take chat GPT agreeing with you so so long as
it's a fair prompt."
Nick says, "So you're agreeing you have no idea what you're talking
about and frankly throwing points into chat GPT all night to
try and avoid taking an L lol." Dan says, "No, I am correct."
And trying to give you a graceful way out before even more attorneys
agree with me.
We are talking about the definition of a
Yeah.
But you don't want to rely on attorneys, but instead your wrong
personal view. Doxing is mostly based on intent. This is obvious,
dude. I read this tweet earlier. It's so
murder. Murder is mostly based on intent. If you ignore the fact
that you have to actually kill somebody to for it to make sense,
right?
To argue that a particular crime is mostly based on intent is
so
dedicated.
the intent and the act itself are both crucial components. And
obviously we are
We're disagreeing over whether it it was actually personal information
that was shared. So
by the way this is Dan is Dan isn't even correct here by saying
that a lawyer agrees with him.
The lawyer just like watches the video and goes, "Whoa,
isn't it crazy that Hassan is like doxing people?
There are some states where this might be illegal." No, he doesn't
get into the California law at all cuz he practices in Florida
and he's got no clue what he's talking about. He watches Dan's
video and goes, "Oh yeah, huh. Oh yeah."
So stupid.
In the same way that if I was to send a message to somebody on
Twitter saying, "Hey, cool. Yeah, you can send the passage to
my package to my sister's house here
would not be doxing, but let's destroy this." This is guys,
you're lost in the source. He says,
dude.
Oh my god." And I looked at this earlier.
Dan Sultman has redacted all of his DMs with Dioro.
Dude, Dan is so sensitive over this over this stuff. It's insane.
H I feel though I feel though what what in particular has actually
really upset Dan isn't any of the claims about you know is this
doxing? Isn't this doxing?
Have you completely humiliated yourself?
Have you not completely humiliated yourself? It's Dioro saying
this is why I don't want to do a show with you. That is what
has really got Dan's go in my opinion. I don't think he cares
about anything else. Not at all. Not at all.
No. No.
There we are.
Um.
Oh my god. What the is this tweet role? Siren emoji.
New commentary cabal. Siren emoji.
Agie
hosted by Jay Talk. Last night, the fate was decided for Willie
Mack, Dioro, Tommy C, Saltman, and Assan.
Wait. Oh, okay. I I guess you couldn't you probably couldn't
tag any of these people because if I'm going to bet, you're probably
blocked by all of them, aren't you? No.
Don't pick a fight with Nick. Um, I don't know about that. I
don't know about that. I think I think picking fights with Nick
is fine. Like, again, through all of that, you can say that Nick
aped him. Not really. Most of what Nick said was just talking.
But I do agree with Nick. So, you know, I don't think that Nick
has particularly argued his point well there. He's just mocked
him for the most part, right? You know, there we are. Anyway,
anyway, nah, it's Yorio saying that Dan is uh anything aside
from perfect boy because Dan gets visions from his father. Jesus,
Resi,
hell, mate. All right, hop in VC. What's going on, Ry? You all
right,
how's it going? You're okay. Hopefully to help. Uh I'm doing
good, man. It's uh uh I was about to talk about the weather.
I realized that might identify my location. So, uh it's sunny
here, you know. It's great. How are you? America, I'm guessing.
Roughly, you know, um this the kind of middle portion of North
America, which I fear is already given away too much, but I figured
uh I've got a little bit of insight. Obviously, you have plenty
of time in Destiny uh watching
um and you know that segment can only be so long with the tweets
that are out there. Um since you you watched the Dioro stream
with Dan last night, is that right? Yeah. Yeah, I watched that
earlier. That was really really funny. What' you think? Um
I feel like Dioro didn't argue the point very well, but I agree
with his I agree with his argument. I just don't think he he
didn't argue it very well and so Dan was able to like slip through
it. But I feel like Dan was like Dan is like a level one blob
in terms of arguing with him. If you disagree and try and argue
with him, he will like he will jump on the worst arguments to
defend himself that just look good to no
Somebody said in chat earlier that Dan is like autistic. I don't
know if that's true. He seems pretty like socially kind of okay
to me, but the fact that he doesn't understand how his arguments
sound to other people makes me think that Yeah. Yeah, he is kind
of I do wonder though cuz I feel like Nick is smart enough to
have argued better. I wonder if Nick didn't want to go in because
he wants to kind of still have Dan Sultman on his stream, right?
No. Well, so if he does, he's So this is this is my I mean, look,
I'm I'm astroturfing or whatever. I'm stealing these takes from
people I listen to, but like Dan Saltman is just a he's an advocate,
right? That's what he is unfortunately or fortunately. He uh
his whole thing cap, you know, fighting against Twitch, it's
all, you know, cuz they they slided Destiny back in the day by
banning it. He's talked about this. And he's also said,
"Look, I have no problem lying if it suits my ends." Mhm. That's
just a
And he says that outright.
just like you deal with a troll,
you do not engage. To engage is to lose.
And Dioro engaged.
Uh you know, however, you know, he he dipped his toes in. He
had that friendly stream.
And this is what's happening, right? Is that Dioro's now
he's got some he's got some opinions of his own. He's having
his little opinions. And that's not okay. You've got to either
you're either like you said in the the infamous anything else
dream from Australia. You're either all the way in or you're
all the way out. And uh Dioro is not all the way in and Dan doesn't
like that.
Yeah, I feel like I probably agree with Um yeah, I probably agree.
I think Dan gets incredibly frustrated documents as
I wonder if Nick knows that. I did like your I liked your comment
about uh how I'm I'm probably blocked by all those people I couldn't
tag. That was a good one also. though.
Oh, you It is almost certainly true though. For sure.
I didn't check. I didn't try to tag them, but then I thought
through each name and I go, you know, you're right. God damn
it.
Made by all those people. They don't blocked. Oh, but yeah. No,
you're right about So, Dan Dan is just he's look, he's um Dioro,
I think, is looking for
he's looking for his next gig. Right. Because I think Ethan is
look, the tides are turning. The tides are turning. It's so obvious
that people are getting tired of Ethan. You, you know, it's just
there was something interesting said. Um, but like I, you know,
that's the challenge, right? Is is what do you think about? So,
in Dioro's audience, he's got all of these Ethan fans because
I mean,
if you were in the same position as Dioro, that's my question.
If you're in the same position, what would you do? Do you do
you stick to your principles where if you let's say you gain
you go from, you know, what are you at 15 viewers? Uh,
If you're at 100 viewers, right? And and you go to a thousand,
right? You you go to a thousand, right? Yeah. You go to a,000
overnight for for sucking who would be somebody you would like
for sucking off queens whatever sucking queen's you get a,000.
You're at a,000 viewers. That doesn't the math doesn't make sense,
but whatever.
and he then starts saying some then what you know or say as gold
it makes more sense
you're in a difficult position right because you've got like
a monetary incentive not to do it but I I this feels like the
take that everyone gives
and I feel like for the majority of people if you're actually
put in that position it's not true but me personally I feel like
especially doing a live stream and like sitting down and just
not having to think about it but just do it and I'd find it very
very hard to actually like give takes day in day out that I don't
actually agree with. Right.
I feel like realistically you would
at some point surely you'd have to I don't know. I don't know.
I I don't think I could do it but obviously that's what everyone
is going to say anyway. So who cares, right? I don't know. I
don't think I could but yeah.
Have you ever been in that position where um you had somebody
come around like tipster comes in chat? No, you know, but there
there are people that sniff around where you have to oh, there's
there's the Perry thing, but he didn't have anything to you didn't
have anything to gain from that. Um, yeah, I mean, situation
had come up, I'm sure, where you've had to make decisions about
who to who to partner with, so to speak, or who to who to ally
with, even in just you're giving your own independent takes,
but there is a
Yeah. I I have I have had that before. Um, for example, the argument
between morale and gamma, like it's no secret that I've got like
I guess a personal association with gamma that's closer than
my personal association with morale. But when they had like a
huge fallout, I think a lot of people were on morale's side.
Uh, and morale was like a big content big much bigger content
creator than Gamma to be able to like associate with, especially
in the streaming niche. And so from a business point of view,
I guess it would have made sense to partner with Morau. Not that
any of this was even that serious, by the way, but it did seem
as though they were burning the bridge at the time. And so picking
one side or the other would, you know, I did consider that. But
no, I gave my take side of Gamma over it. Um,
you decided Gamma
and Gamma is your your boy.
Uh, what did you have any critiques for
Uh, I did and I gave those at the same
Yeah, fair enough. Fair enough. Yeah, I won't ask you to recite
them. It's just I look I I just all I when I say it is like
I think I roughly stick to my principles but unfortunately I
would say
look I was in sales. I was commission based. Money is over a
lot of things for me, unfortunately. And I'm just happy to admit
that, right? It doesn't not something I'm proud of, right? But
it's just it's the way the world works. And anyone who lies
when you're given 10x your revenue, whatever your viewership,
I think a lot of people think they can make, look, I hate Dioro
for other reasons. I just think he's soft.
But look, if you're put in that position where you put a 10x
multiplier on your like most video games don't have weekends
with double they're like double or triple XP and then that's
a fake number on they won't even give you 10x XP on a weekend
right but if you you know you start you know giving a certain
take that you maybe you felt because Dorio probably agreed with
Ethan in the beginning right earnestly. Yeah, he earnestly felt
a certain way about Hassan, felt a certain way about Ethan and
that one and one lined up with his principles and then his viewership
goes up. So that that's what's crazy. It's it's a weird order
of events
and then slowly he starts drifting away and you start seeing
some of the gaps in the logic. You see that he's kind of just
making ADL talking points and you see and I think people, as
much as I hate Dior, I think people really discount how tough
that would be to turn that down. Um,
personally,
this might be an unpopular take, I don't think Dioro is actually
lying about the position that he holds, right?
I don't think I don't think Dior is like lying about these positions.
I think realistically,
even if you do have a selection
bias towards stuff in terms of arguments that you will and won't
make publicly, that's what you're going to do. You're going to
like there's a line there. You've got certain views that go against
the person who you're kind of like championing or like supporting
during a drama. You've taken their side. You've got certain certain
arguments that go for them and certain points that like go against
them. And you there might just be a subtle pressure to kind of
keep those points that go against them quiet, right? Because
you like the person or you feel like it detracts from your point
overall or if I say this and somebody just takes that in isolation,
does that really service my entire like view of this point? Maybe
I could see people doing that. I don't think that some I don't
think Dorio is actually lying about his positions, though. I
think he believes what he's saying. I think it it it hearkens
back to my time in DGG, right? is where it's it's like when you're
watching a movie and and
the animation is not great and the story is not great and you
suspend the disbelief at first and then slowly you're like, "Oh,
[__] dude. This is really bad." What do they spend
$100? Did they get their cousin to do the animations? I can't
go buy this [__] You know, there you can see them
like faking rocking on the spaceship as it goes into hypers speed.
You're like, Jesus, this is I can't buy into this. I just I think
eventually
you do see the cracks but because there are so many people around
you who agree with you you can just you can you can close your
eyes and pretend it's real for a bit you know pretend you actually
believe those things but I think when queen or you or they catch
some ad on Twitter who calls out and shows you and then you have
to make that gay whatever gay response that is part of the cabal
whatever cabal you know response you have that doesn't really
prove the other side wrong I think that's like you have like
that moment of clarity where you go, "Yeah." And but you make
the decision to, you know, go right back into that, you know,
suspension of disbelief. Maybe I think without like a uh with
like a concrete analysis or like looking through like Nick's
actual coverage, I'd find it kind of hard to tell. I mean, Queman's
in chat, he says uh he doesn't just keep them quiet, he actively
downplays and disregards.
He doesn't just keep them quiet. I'm guessing he means like arguments
that go against Ethan. He actively downplays and disregards.
He's been blatantly dishonest multiple times. Uh you probably
know Quimman's Dorio's coverage better than I do just cuz I don't
watch his streams very often. Um but yeah,
maybe I don't know. It'd have to be a thing where you could like
point out
particular examples, right? That'd be the thing. Um, but yeah,
if I could look at an example, that' probably be like trying
to think of an example where he's been like blatantly dishonest.
I don't know. I don't know. So, so there the last the last controversy
was the the sword. The sword was the the swastika sword. I think
that's okay.
He does believe that that is a swastika sword. I don't think
he's been dishonest. The swastika sword
was the worst. I think I think you're you're
I don't think you're being honest there. I think he's you can't
I don't think Dioro is a smart guy. You don't see the swastika
sword and you [__] go that is anti-semitic.
Uh I just I don't think Dioro said that it was anti-Semitic or
that Assan was intentionally doing it to be
Does Does Dioro think that Assan is actually an anti-Semite
or does he just think that it was like to with him? No. Well,
I mean, but I think that the point was that it was on purpose.
Was Yeah. Yeah.
Antiatic is very, very One sec. Quit says, "I show an example
in the Augie convo. I don't know if Royal has it to hand about
the denims chat scrolling clip."
sweat for that. Let me uh pull up the transcript.
cuz you just uploaded that to uh to Raw Kitten House, didn't
you? Yeah. Hold on.
No, I think he did say it was to with him. Yeah. Yeah, that's
what I thought. There we go. So, we got It's not about whether
it's a swastika sword. It's about whether he believes it was
intentionally used. Yeah. Whether it lines up previous assessments
of dog whistles slash with similar levels of evidence. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Again, I don't think he's right. I disagreed with
with Yuri over the sword. Um I just thought it was like a funny
it was a funny thing that happened, but anyone trying to paint
it as anything else than that? Yeah.
There's a couple instances of denims in the transcript. Oh, sorry.
There's a couple of denims in the transcript here. So, but it's
Queen and talking. So, I just sent you the time stamp we can
pull
I'll share my screen. Sounds good.
Okay, I'll go to the time stamp. And Denims and Snark as all
one entity and blaming the CPS call on them with no
a standard that would never have been held with with careful
But like those names you brought up like bad empanada was the
guy that made the video with the narrative that Ethan's like
abusing his children basically. But you can't Yes. Yes. But we
would usually so bad empanada you can say bad empardada made
a bad faith malicious Yeah. It's a different time stamp because
it's brought up a couple times here. Bear with me. Ah, apparently
he brings up a clip of the stream and a tweet.
Yeah, I got you here. Is it right at the Nick's tweet about denims
at I got you here. Time stamp. Cheers, mate. 130 131. here's
Nick tweets. Nick's tweet about denims. Yeah, hold on. Let's
see it. I like the snarker narrative that Ethan claims Denim's
let her live chat scroll up randomly and block the entire stream.
Anyone with half a brain knows that these chats don't match the
order of the ones shown on screen in the top corner. There is
no context manipulation at all. Yeah, that's what I Yeah. Okay.
So, I did have it right. Okay, perfect.
There's no context migration at all, dude. That's a complete
just
because just showed up here and was like, "Wait, I thought everybody
was saying this." Well, see, this is why debate I do agree a
debate needs to happen. You know,
I mean, okay, pause it real quick. Yeah. Yeah. So, see, so this
is DGG. This is a Destiny. That's a Destiny video and our Destiny
video where what they did is they took basically instead of showing
what looked like a live chat, they filtered the chat. They filtered
the chat message
show the CPS
and the bad ones. So what they did is they made it look like
it was a scroll. Yeah. Right. Like this is the live chat and
it's just chocked full of hate and uh hateful rhetoric. But it's
really what could be over the course of hours, right? Which I
think is what ended up being or at least dozens of minutes. More
of this. You just need to wind this back. see how this come cuz
basically what happens is
brings this up or this comes up and he's like oh yeah wasn't
denim's whole chat saying call CPS and I immediately I I pick
up on that and we go from there and we go over this tweet and
then we go over the clip of Nick's stream from a month ago where
he last talked about this and we look at how he addresses this
when it comes up in the denim's attempt to sue Ethan. Do you
remember? So you you need to see some context of this that was
in the com that point was like most prominently made in the uh
the Idubbbz content cop right or was it the content deputy? I
think it was the content deputy have that in the content deputy
about the chat amount. I'm 99% sure cuz he talks about the uh
he talks about his camera going to close it up, right?
You remember that? He had the little tracking uh rectangle. Did
he talk about that? I'm 99% sure that's where that that was most
prominently made. Let me double check because I'm wondering what
what uh Dura's reaction was at the time. I'm sure we can find
a V of that. Hello everyone. Welcome back to another episode
of Content Deputy. Now, normally in a content, Here it is. Oh,
yeah. Every comment, I believe this is a live feed of the chat.
So, I'd be in Yeah, cuz Ethan claims that it is a live feed of
of the chat. I do wonder what Dioro's response to that would
be.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I've got the one I've got is from the Denim's
attempt to sue. Ah, okay. Okay. Um that's fair. I'll probably
have a look at the clip here and then actually I'll go back and
see what Doria said about that time cuz I can take a look at
the the VODs off the top. Yeah. Do you remember what Doria said
about this? Not in the tweet, but like at the
Wait, does it actually watch the This is so Oh my god, this is
so lame. What? I'm just listen. I'm watching
these idiots coverage. Is it cut out of the VOD?
Dude, look. No, I've got it right here. Look, this is this is
when Nick addresses it in the content debut.
Look, I'm time it two dickers. Cheers, man. Pull this up, dude.
This guy's like so sloppy. It's so
There we are. Who's cheering him on while he's doing Combines
them. It's one chat on one stream at different points to make
it seem like someone is coordinating an attack on you. Love uh
made a a good point. You said, "Is this someone is literally
coordinating an attack on him?" Absolutely.
I believe this is a live feed of the chat. This isn't edited.
What about the top right? I I thought these were No, this I think
when you full screen it. No, this is an edit. It's a cutout of
the full and then he plays the clip where Ethan explicitly tells
you okay that they clipped the chat and it's like a cutout of
it chat that's just enlarged there.
Yeah, it's just it's a cut out that's just enlarged but it's
not it's filtered. It's filtered to only include the relevant
messages that make his But what Nick is saying is oh Ethan said
that it was just cut out explained it. Ethan explained it. You're
if you don't realize what's happening here it's just a cutout.
Look, it's it's he's explained it. It's obvious. It's you're
[__] And so everyone still thinks people don't even
take in this criticism. Everyone is here. Nick is deliberately
spoiling, downplaying, and disregarding this criticism. So that
everyone watches like, "Yeah, Ethan was right. Ethan was just
said the right thing." Yeah, her whole chat was saying that they
were coordinating. Our whole chat was saying that. And that's
how everyone walks away from it. I mean, the thing is because
he is being You can just correspond what the chat messages are
here and what the chat messages are there completely different.
Like where's that little smiley face there? Where are the two?
Like Yeah, it's just it's just obvious. I think I think Ethan
even took the L on this, didn't they? When he reacted to the
content deputy, he said, "Yeah, my bad."
I don't remember. I think I've Yeah. Yeah. There was a moment
someone called it out as being from Destiny's subreddit. Somebody
had called him out from this being a subreddit video. I think
Hassan did, right? He said, "You got this from our Destiny."
And he had to kind of like eat that one. I feel like, but that's
a vague memory. Yeah. Yeah. I'm 99% sure. Even Even Ethan said,
"Yeah, I got that one wrong." I say, "What's he going on to say
about this, though?"
It's it's directly explained to you in the stream what exactly
this is. Like, love literally says it's not It's not timed the
same way. It's not timed the same way. Like, all of the context
is in the clip and he's as in it's delayed. No, it's slow. Yeah.
As in it's scrolling slowly. Yeah. Anyone watching this will
come away thinking that's just her chat like obviously, right?
Yeah, cuz that's what Ethan is clearly communicating. Yeah.
yeah. And then Nick is backing it up.
Just show that to people. But it sounds like based on this clip,
you knew that it was and you just went with it anyway. It's not.
Denims has confirmed in her own video that those messages did
come from her chat and all of it is actually 6% of the messages
that we actually from the start of that scroll to the end. Only
6% of the messages in that time frame are shown. Nick, that's
not what Ethan's communicating there, is it? He's obviously communicating
that they're all like that. It's so dumb.
Oh, I I it seems like he's just gone in to watch the video to
disagree with Idubbbz because Idubbbz is wrong. I mean, I don't
know if you've watched any That's what he's done the whole time.
That's all he's done the whole time. Yes, it's been most of Science
coverage all time. Yes, obviously. I don't know if you've watched
any of his coverage of the Creator Class stuff. I don't think
it's so much like his love of Ethan Klein, more so like
with Anita. No, it's a session with
You think so?
it is the it is the common narrative that Idubbbz has been like
completely
by Anissa which is really really weird cuz Idubbbz is like in
his 30s at this point now. I don't know. Yeah, he wants to Well,
she she she espouses Nazi talking points. So, she's the forbidden
fruit. Oh my god. That clip was that Dan Saltman as well talking
about the Holocaust. You know the clip I'm talking about, right?
I think that's old as old as [__] People have always
gi
one sec.
All of it is after
the Wait, I'm actually so confused. How is that a win condition
if all the messages are from the Denim stream after Denim's uncritically
watches bad empanada? Why would that be invalidated? And they
explain in the clip what they're
They're different. Because because it's not the total message
is a tiny fraction of a huge amount of messages
many viewers
like it's it's not the same as it being the entire chat obviously
but those can easily slip through moderation. It could be they
weren't moderated could be they just didn't see it as a big enough
issue cuz only a few people were saying it. Plenty of reasons
but it is absolutely materially different to that being the entire
chat. Yeah. the way it is presented, the way that Nick is allowing
it to be. He's backing up that presentation, too. Because at
no point here is he saying, "No, that's selected for only the
CPS messages." No, that's selected for only the He's not He's
not actually making it clear what is happening. He's just saying
Ethan is right. And he's sort of going, "Uh oh, well, how is
it not right? How is it not right? It was clarified in the clip
already." But the argument that Ethan's given is obviously Yeah.
totally dishonest here. Yeah. And the thing is as well an argument
made by Ethan Klein, he is a little bit of a Dan Sultman where
he will reach just to be able to like make an argument that he
that he wants to make kind of targeted against like a I don't know
like an enemy of his. So I feel like you should already be a
little bit careful as soon as you're like listening to Ethan
Klein trying to make an argument. You know, there was the Noah
Samson girl, there was the fresh and fit girl. He will just have
random girls on to make vaguely hateful and you know claims about
people with no backing of like no verification of their messages,
no lining up the timelines and just allow people to just
hateful uh accusations.
uh yeah yeah maybe maybe yeah I could see that. I can see what
you mean. Yeah. going to watch one of us love him with Thinks
the chat messages are fake because it says edited.
Denims doesn't even contest that. Wait, it says edited time the
same way. But it sounds like based on this clip, you knew that
it was bull. Idubbbz thinks the chat messages are fake because
it says edited. Where does it say? Doesn't even contest that
and you just went with it anyway. Ethan Klein uses this very
deceptively edited That would be significant if a huge like if
if if all those messages were completely fake. That would be
a whole different argument. No, no, no. That's not even being
contested right Deceptively edited. He's saying deceptively edited.
Well, I don't even know where he's getting the fact that Idubbbz
is is like
I don't know where he's getting the fact that Idubbbz is saying
it's fabricated. That is just like doing this smooth scroll to
make it seem What is a smooth scroll? Like that's all of Denim's
chat, but that's not the chat's on the screen. You can see the
real chat. Bro, you need to play the video. I need you to play
the video. This is so manipulative. But it sounds like based
on this clip, you knew that it was and you just went with it
anyway. Ethan CL. Okay, there's nothing more to be gained from
this. Let's take a look at the at the live stream with Augie.
Oh, wait. Did you go through it again when Ethan is reacting
to it? Cuz Ethan takes the illness point. Okay. Okay. Okay. Here
we are. Here we are.
So, at first I made that mistake. I genuinely thought I want
to point out that Frogan is more mature and empathetic than you.
She said that's taking the L. Uh she said she denounced the cops
calling CBS and lies about the family. She also dude he has proven
himself to be a manipulative piece of so you've been harboring
these feelings for years then. It's not even just when like when
you like this personal thing that just happened to you video
that takes context
get ready to have your mind blown. This is the dumbest thing
I've ever seen in any video ever. This is the get ready like
three different places. They were real good friends. Well, Idubbbz
switches up in this video. It's like we were friends for eight
years.
To make it seem like someone is coordinating an attack on you.
Are you not told who calls child protective services on you?
Is it confidential every time?
Wait, you think that if you put in a a phone call to CPS, they're
required by That's so stupid. No, like no one would ever do that
if that was the case. Of course, it's confidential. Love made
a a good point. You said, "Is Oh, no. Not that bad timing." Um,
sorry. I believe this is a live feed of the That would Yeah,
that would cause Ethan even says, "I believe this is a live feed
of the chat."
So many issues.
What about the top right? I I thought these were No, this I think
when you full screen it. No, this is an edit. It's a cutout of
the full chat. Nick, is he dumb or a complete sellout liar? We're
a month in and I don't know. I keep going towards dumb now. The
more I watch Ian, the dumber I realize he is. Um, it could be
that he's so,
but I I don't know. He seems like a real
It's just enlarged over the screen. they're different. Oh, so
so at first I made that mistake. I genuinely thought I want to
point out that Froggen is more mature and empathetic than me.
She said, why is he reading the
That was deliberate. That was this this is deliberate. This is
like the oldest trick in the book. This is what you do when you
make this is like the oldest trick in the book. When as a streamer
when you're watching someone else's like hit piece and you you
typically you have a really bad point that you know you're going
to eat your ass on. You just you read a chat in the middle. You
pause through the uh uh proposition right through as it's making
the main point. you just pause directly in the middle because
that is going to disrupt the thought process and you can't be
held accountable for what you were you know hey I wasn't reading
the chat I wasn't paying attention
I mean the problem is that
that it it
is give it plausible deniability
but it does genuinely give you plausible
that's the issue I don't know let's see let's see cuz we we haven't
got all of what Nick's saying yet okay
she said she denounced the cops calling CBS and lies about the
family. She also didn't talk around the topic like Ian. I guess
you're probably right. Yeah,
I don't know. It depends
the guy orbit.
I will say though, yeah, I didn't really see Frogan engage with
that. It was more like every other person than Frogan. I guess
I can give Frogan a W there, but it might just be because she
wasn't watched enough to see what she had to say about it. Like
Frogan is objectively the smallest person. I can correct you
about it. Love corrected you. Yeah, you you were being a boomer,
but I think it was very clear for
I think you were the only one that thought that. Well, right.
Okay, maybe. But then her explanation is just like, oh yeah,
that was only 50 messages over 5 minutes. Right. This argument
that sounds horrible, right? It this is not what podcasting is.
This argument uh Oh, thank you for hitting the goal. It. Yes.
Not even paying attention. Those chat messages are are not the
entirety of the chat. That's correct. It's just some of the chat.
I don't personally think that that makes it much better. Completely
immaterial,
Considering how many there are. No comment. Uh the content cop
and deputy maybe
better if the editing and script were in the same.
I called it. This is so dishonest. He's so incapable of taking
a iota of criticism. And yeah, I'll be honest. I'm not sure.
I It's not just cuz it's Nick. All right. Anyone who's watched
any of my content will know that I am generally pretty hesitant
before I start labeling things as dishonest. Okay? I give a lot
of charity when it looks as though someone's being dishonest.
That is just the easiest thing to throw. Being dishonest.
We've got four months of being dishonest. This isn't like a oh
man, this 100% truthful guy. This 100% truthful guy just happened
to take a donut at that time. And he's he's listening to him
talk about the chats. He's hearing the words. The words are,
"Hey, yeah, yeah. There there's 50 chats in 5 minutes. That's
completely different than just a mirror image. It's completely
contradicting your entire point." And he's going, "Oh, thanks
for hitting the dot goal, Johnny."
Well, I was saying, Ry, okay. I was
this does look very bad. This does look really, really bad. I'll
be honest. Oh my god. I do wonder if Dioro was uh was going ahead
and just kind of
This doesn't look good. Okay, this isn't okay, Ethan. This doesn't
look This doesn't look great. Okay, this doesn't look fantastic.
It's just ignoring it. Oh, yeah. Okay. Okay. I could say maybe
this is slightly slightly icky. It's a little icky. Yeah. Little
little smelly. Little fishy. Maybe. Maybe. Yeah. Okay. It looks
pretty bad. I'll give you the I'll give you the [__]
hell.
You absolutely can call this dishonest
when it's happened a thousand times.
Okay. I'll be I'll be honest. Okay. I just don't watch I don't
watch Yorio content like other people do in the space. It It
feels like just cuz I'm not familiar with these other examples.
I can't stand it. Me neither. I just it's uh if you're up for
it, I want to hear if you want to roll this back. Otherwise,
I'll watch out my own time. I want to hear Auggie bring up the
the CPS call here. If you roll it back like a minute, he said,
"Don't worry. I've hear him." Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I want to hear
him bring it up just like walking into the Oh, do you
Sorry. Go
I um I I can't stand I know that other people in the space do
like for the meta commentary like commentating on what other
commentators say. I cannot stand watching somebody else walk
through like points or walk through content that I've already
reacted to on stream or I've already like looked through and
just be
"Oh, yeah, I get it. I get it. I get it." Or I disagree and then
I just get frustrated and angry.
Well, there's no room to talk, right? Cuz who there's five people
in commentary on cam or on uh on mic, right? So, even if you
want to talk, usually somebody's making the point before you
do. Um, but like I can watch this offline and I don't have to
hold you here hostage. Yeah. Yeah. No, no. I'm excited for Nick
said, you know what Nick said about Watch most of this offline.
Yeah. I took a quick look at and it seemed like it was nothing
but boring. Wow. So, just to be clear, we're going to have to
that that that screenshot cuz I've seen the like the video of
her chat moving, right? It's not just that they clipped like
10 seconds of it, right? They showed specifically the chat moving
where like almost everyone was like, "Holy call CPS, whatever."
Right? But that was just like an edited version where it it uh
it only shows the people that typed CPS in there. I feel like
I watched this Denim's video though. Like how would I not have
noticed this? He's walking right into the He's walking right
into it. It was only like mentions of like CPS kids jardia or
something like that. It was like a couple of keywords that were
filtered down. But the way so obviously initially it's it's brought
up on the H3 podcast and basically they they say about they say
about it like um I mean we probably watch clips here but they
they're like oh it's edited and Ethan's like yeah yeah but it's
just like it's just like pulled up and slowed down. It's just
like pulled up and it's just like pulled from the chat and slowed
down and that's what's been ran with the whole time is yeah it
is it's obviously an edited video. You can see it the chat has
just been pulled okay so thank I'll chat to you later buddy.
Yeah, I feel what you're feel I feel what you're feeling. I'm
like I've said we just did all this. All right, cool. All right,
take it easy. I'll chat to you later, bud. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We just ran through the exact same argument. What I'm interested
to hear, though, is I do want to hear what Auggie's reaction
to this
From what I've heard,
Auggie's been relatively harsh.
Auggie has been relatively harsh with uh with Willie. I don't
know how he's gonna take it with Nick CPS like he's abusing kids
blah blah blah. So
huh where's the data analysis she does where she shows the messages
that were mentioning CPS within that time frame 6.8%
in that time frame.
Yeah. So from the first message to the last message that's shown
in that scroll
um it's 956 messages but only 65 of them are shown. Oh wait I
might have been wrong. Denims might have
Did Denims do it first? Okay.
Yeah, I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Are I? Yeah. Okay. The stream
didn't die. Can we chill out, lads? Hell, the stream didn't die.
I effed for like two seconds.
Now, okay. The chat. This isn't edited. When was this published?
May 3rd. And then this is
Wait, March 2023. Oh, March
is like totally
6.8%. Yeah. I mean, and Ethan's out there. Ethan's out there
saying Denim's did CPS. Denim's did CPS. People are going, "Oh,
these guys, these people called CPS on him. They can he can do
whatever the he wants." That is the line. That is the line constantly.
And it is like all built on so many
lies. First of all, like this